(tranquil music)
The problem is not democracy.
At this point, our system is so corrupt.
It's become a system of legalized bribery.
(logo whooshes)
People know it.
It's not like people are not aware,
and it's not like people are not upset,
but we're all living with this conundrum:
what do we do?
We are now at a point where it's not just
that we must move in another direction,
but we must move quickly.
We have to become as convicted behind our love
as some people are convicted behind their hate.
(gust whooshes)
Greetings, internet, it is I, Rich Roll, your host.
Welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is a teacher.
She's an activist, a thought leader,
and the author of 14 books, 4 of which
have been number-one "New York Times" bestsellers.
Her name is Marianne Williamson,
and if that name sounds familiar,
it might be because she's an absolute legend
in spiritual circles, but more likely,
it's because she quite famously ran for presidents in 2020,
so this is a conversation
about that fascinating chapter in her life,
but more broadly,
it's also about what's required
to solve our most urgent problems.
It's about the perils of our entrenched
corporate- slash government- slash media-industrial complex.
It's about the legacy of '60s activism,
the role of spirituality in politics, the relationship
between personal evolution and global change
and many other topics.
Marianne is a badass.
I really enjoyed this one,
so please, click that subscribe button,
hit that notification bell,
and enjoy what I think
is a very insightful and fascinating conversation
with the force of nature
known as Marianne Williamson.
Marianne, I'm so happy to have you here today.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you,
I'm happy to be here, honored.
Yeah, I been looking forward to this for a long time.
Thank you.
So many threads that we can pull on,
but I think a good place to start
is just talking
about where we find ourselves right now.
Obviously, we live in very interesting times.
It's a very unique period
that I haven't experienced in my lifetime,
in terms of the division and the divisiveness
and the acrimony and this era of social media,
so I suppose I'm just curious:
how are you feeling
about this current moment
(Marianne chuckles)
that we find ourselves in?
I think all of us are feeling rather discombobulated
by the whole thing,
but what we're thinking about, I think, is very important.
I think we're living in two simultaneous realities.
I think, on one hand, it is the fall of Rome.
On one hand, it is the dissembling of a civilization,
a cratering of American civilization, in many ways.
And on the other hand, it is the dawning
and the struggling to be born of a new world,
a new renaissance.
I think they're both true,
and I think that we are called upon
to be both death doulas and birth doulas.
It's our job to help that which, in many ways, has to die
to die tenderly and with as little harm as possible
and with as just a transition as possible
and to passionately and vigorously give birth
to a world that works.
It's just like when we were children,
and we were taught about evolution.
If a species moves in a direction
where its collective behavior is increasingly maladaptive
for its survival,
one of two things will happen:
either that species will go extinct,
or a mutation will occur.
It will evolve in a different direction,
and I think that that's what's happened in many ways
to our democracy, and certainly, it's happened
to the entirety of the human race.
We're moving in directions that are increasingly maladaptive
for the survival of the species.
We will now turn.
We will now move in a different direction.
We will now mutate and evolve,
or global cataclysm,
catastrophe on a level that most of us can't even imagine,
is a very real possibility.
Yeah, it does feel like this epic arms race
of light versus dark,
which is obviously a touchdown theme
in your teachings and what you talk about.
If we root this in the political landscape,
the difference in the tenor of our moment
is this ticking clock in the background, right?
We could quibble
about policy changes and the direction of the country
and where we're at as a collective consciousness
and address those items
in a kind of incremental way,
but now we have this looming existential threat
that elevates the urgency of all of this
and, I think, also exacerbates the antipathy
and everything else that's going on right now
that makes it this crucible
where it's very difficult
to figure out the best way forward.
And I'd like that idea that you mentioned
around evolution of the individual
and how that is reflected
in society at large.
It's this idea of ontogeny recapitulates phylogeny.
You can't evolve the whole
without the evolution of the individual.
I think the issue of incrementalism that you mentioned
is very relevant.
I think it was in the "Letter from the Birmingham Jail"
that Martin Luther King talked about incrementalism,
and he said, "If you take an incremental approach to change,
then the status quo,
which will never seek to disrupt itself,
will simply co-opt the ideas."
What's happening right now
is that even those who are standing for workable solutions
and a more sustainable future...
There's a tendency of the economic and the political system
to provide too little, too slow, too late.
We have taken it to a point now...
So many of the solutions being offered,
for instance, even right now
by the Biden presidency, et cetera,
they shoulda been offered in 1995.
We are now at a point
where it's not just that we must move in another direction,
but we must move quick
because as you said, the risk is so great.
When I think of things like protest against the Vietnam War,
passionate, important, huge,
but when we thought about the worst that could happen,
global cataclysm was not the worst that could happen.
We're now living at a time
where the worst that could happen, global catastrophe
on a level, like I said, we can't even imagine.
It's a complete shift psychologically, I think,
that we have to move into,
and if you make that move without any consideration
of larger, more expanded sense of possibility,
almost from a metaphysical perspective,
then you were left
with understandable nihilism, cynicism, anger, and fear
because if you only look at this moment
from a rational perspective,
it could be argued it's over.
It could be argued that the gig is up.
I think of it much like when the Israelites were standing
at the Red Sea.
If they go forward, they'll drown.
If they go back...
Pharaoh had decided he wanted his slaves back
and sent his soldiers to go get them
or to kill them if they refuse to come.
That story, like all stories of miraculous transformation,
indicate that there's a level of consciousness
at which the laws of time and space,
as we know them, are transcended.
If you think of the abolitionist movement,
there was no reason
from a rational perspective
to think that slavery could be abolished,
given how ensconced it was within the economy of the South.
If you look at the women's suffragette movement,
there was no reason to think that women could gain suffrage,
given how infused the system was
with the institutionalized oppression and suppression
of women's rights.
Even if you look at the civil rights movement,
there was no reason from a rational perspective
to think that it could succeed,
given how embedded the systemic racism
and institutionalized suppression
of the rights of black people were
within the systems of segregation in the American South,
and yet these changes occur.
They have occurred in American history,
and they've occurred throughout the world.
And I think we need to keep our eyes on those moments
where very (snaps) quickly
in a way that no (snaps) one might've predicted,
the right prevailed, love prevailed,
justice prevailed, mercy prevailed
that there was such a burst of yearning and passion
for those things within enough human hearts
that humanity moved in that direction.
Yeah, I suppose there is a seed of hopefulness
that can be mined
in thinking about those instances,
but I can't help but reflect
upon the inadequacies
of a democratic system
that is systemically ensconced
in an incremental way
of progressing change
with this ticking clock and this existential...
Do we have enough time?
Is there adequate political will?
Is there too much denial?
Is the corporate stranglehold
on that political will
too powerful to really create the change
that we're gonna need in order to survive (laughs)
as a species and as a thriving planet.
Well, let's deconstruct that.
The problem is not democracy.
The problem is the anti-democratic force field
represented by the corporatized political duopoly
that now is keeping the will of the people
from being expressed in political terms.
If you look at issue after issue,
the problem is not the American people.
the consciousness of the American people is not the problem.
The problem is how often the will of the American people,
because of gerrymandering,
because of the corporatized forces
within both political parties
that peripheralize any non-corporate-backed candidates,
now voter suppression, rights,
and, first and foremost, the money,
the undue influence of money on our politics,
so democracy is the answer.
The problem is that our democracy is not now functioning
as a democracy.
Right, old-school democracy,
democracy as originally-
Well, we've never been perfect, but yeah,
at this point, our system is so corrupt
it's become a system of legalized bribery.
People know it.
It's not like people are not aware,
and it's not like people are not upset,
but we're all living with this conundrum:
what do we do?
Yeah, the distinction between the voters
and the systemic ills
of a democratic system that's been co-opted
by corporate interests,
so in looking at that problem or that dilemma,
how do we untangle that knot
and get the democratic system back on the rails
so that it can function in the manner
in which it was originally conceived
and not be held hostage
by the corporations
that seem to dictate policy
on every level?
Well, with the current make-up of the Supreme Court,
we certainly can assume
that Citizens United will not be overturned anytime soon.
In "Letters to a Young Poet,"
I'm sure, a book that you're well aware of by Rilke,
he says, "There are times when you don't know the answer
but you live with the question,"
and that is a question,
the one you just posed,
that every thinking person that I know
is dealing with right now: "What do we do in 2024?"
The way I look at it,
the Republican Party as it now stands
represents a nose-dive for our democracy,
and the Democratic Party as it now stands,
certainly under the leadership of its corporatized forces,
represents a managed decline of American democracy.
We all know the risk.
You go third party, and you could risk
helping neo-fascist forces get back into power.
You work within the Democratic Party,
and you see what they did to Bernie twice.
I know what they did to me.
(tuts) What is the way forward?
I'm living with the question in my heart
and most people I know
are living with the question in their hearts.
I think that the answers are going to emerge
because I think the anguish of that question
exists in enough of us
and very serious people are doing
very serious thinking and reflection on this question.
Yeah, there's many ways to dissect this.
We could just look at the two-party duopoly
and have a exploration of the possibility of a third party
like Andrew Yang is doing right now,
and he was in here recently talking about that,
and he's got a series of ideas about how to untie this knot.
We can look at incremental policy decisions,
but ultimately, I think
the conversation that I wanna have
and where I think you are uniquely suited to speak to
is the broader conversation
about the crisis of consciousness
that we're experiencing right now,
a situation in which
materialism and consumerism drive priorities.
It's all buttressed
by this government-industrial complex
that's propped up by corporate interests
that places accumulation and comfort
above community and conservation,
all at the cost of our wellbeing, of course.
It's all being denigrated by social media
and these algorithms that foment division and hate,
ultimately dividing us
from each other and from ourselves
and distancing ourselves from the shared fabric
that unites us and creates the cohesion that's required
to function as a healthy society.
I think that there are two points of demarcation
that are worth noting:
one, the advent of the Industrial Revolution
and, second, the advent of trickle-down economics.
It was in the late 1800s
that the Industrial Revolution exploded onto the scene
in England, then in the United States,
and there were quite a few artists
and philosophers, writers, thinkers,
both in Europe and in the United States
who tried to sound an alarm, a warning,
that we were becoming, as a civilization,
so mesmerized by externalities
that we were losing the balance
between the outer and the inner self.
We were losing the balance
with internal issues that were just as important
as what we could see with our physical eyes.
When I was in college,
I had these huge posters on my wall.
Remember when we used to have,
from an art museum,
art posters, right?
And I had these huge angels,
and it said be Burne-Jones,
but I didn't know who Burne-Jones was.
I just knew I loved these huge pictures of angels.
Many years later I was walking
down Fifth Avenue, New York City,
passing the Metropolitan Museum,
and they have these big flags:
"This is what our exhibit is today."
And there were these huge angels
by Edward Burne-Jones.
I was so excited, and I was gonna see them.
I took one of those...
You have that little machine, a little earphone.
They tell you things.
And I already started writing my book
"Healing the Soul of America."
I knew about the transcendentalists,
and I knew about the Industrial Revolution and all of this,
yet I had had no idea that his paintings were part of this.
This is what Burnes-Jones said:
"Every time they build a machine,
I will paint an angel." (chuckles)
(Rich laughs)
He should be painting a lotta angels.
Yeah, he had to paint a lot.
This was the beginning
of this horrifying split
within human consciousness,
and then by the 20th century,
it climaxed with the Industrial Revolution
and this idea that we would solve all of humanities problems
through this mechanistic paradigm,
the Newtonian idea that the world is just a machine
and if you wanna fix it, you just tweak the machine.
Well, obviously that has turned out to not be true,
but the damage has been done
in terms of so much of particularly the Western mind
being drawn so far into the material world
that it has almost withered our spiritual musculature.
Nothing is more of an example of this
than what happened in 1980.
Now, I'm not romanticizing American capitalism before 1980.
I'm not romanticizing or whitewashing the behavior
of corporate interest in this country before 1980,
but I can tell you, I'm old enough to be able to tell you,
that there was a time in my lifetime...
Not that we were perfect,
not that our democracy was perfect,
not that corporate ethics were so exemplary,
but the social consensus was
we were supposed to try.
With the advent of trickle-down economics,
this propaganda, this horrifying canard,
was like wool pulled over the eyes of the American people,
where "if we just increase the stockholder value,
if we just increase the profits,
the short-term profits of your stockholders,
even if at the expense of the other stakeholders,
at the expense of workers,
at the expense of the community,
at the expense of the environment,
this'll be good, see,
because it'll lift all boats.
Those new corporate aristocrats will just create
so many jobs
that money will just trickle down, lift all boats."
Well, obviously, after 40 years,
we can see it did not lift all boats.
It left millions and millions of people
without even a life vest.
I think a lotta people don't realize, in the 1970s,
the average American worker had a decent job
with decent benefits,
could afford a car, could afford a home,
could afford a yearly vacation,
and could afford to send their kids to college.
This is aberrational, this massive transfer of wealth.
It began with Ronald Reagan.
It began with the Republicans,
but no Democratic president has stopped it,
and we're now at a point where, as I said earlier,
the status quo will not disrupt itself.
It's no different than...
It's interesting, Rich, because you and I are coming
from the wellness community, et cetera.
There is very sophisticated thinking within that community
regarding drugs and alcohol,
and it's very sophisticated
because people have known so many people who died.
And we know that if it goes too far...
Most of us have had this situation in our lives.
Either we've made the call
or had someone else make the call to us:
"You think we oughta do something,
because if we don't intervene this person could die."
We need to stop our magical thinking about democracy
and about the survival of the human race.
You continue like this, you could die;
We will lose our democracy.
So at this point, we need to stage an intervention,
and as John F. Kennedy said,
"Those who make peaceful revolution impossible
make violent revolution inevitable,"
and that to me is the point where we are.
(tuts) Yeah, we can identify,
or we can place all our focus on Donald Trump
and label him as a malignant narcissist and the like,
but ultimately,
he's a symbol.
He's a symptom.
He's a reflection of decades
of tectonic economic shifts
that have led to a situation
where people who have been so deprived and unheard
for so long
and have to work three jobs,
as opposed to the one job
that provides the car and the picket fence
and all of that...
Of course, you're gonna have anger and resentment
and all of the emotions
that we're seeing flaring up.
It's reflective of that.
It's either gonna lead
towards some kind of revolutionary act
and the dissolution (laughs) of the union.
Ultimately, there has to be a reckoning, right?
The most healthy way to address it
is to have some form of intervention
where we can course-correct what has gone wrong
and find a way to provide for those people
in a meaningful way
who have been so deprived for too long.
If you look at history,
it's very interesting
to see not only what conditions provided the opportunity
for Hitler to gain power
but also how the United States and the other Allies
responded to that problem
at the end of the war.
At the end of World War I,
the attitude towards Germany on the part of the Allies
was basically reparations in the form of Deutschmark
till we tell you to stop.
Interestingly enough, it was the American president
at the time, Woodrow Wilson,
who tried to warn them that this was a bad idea.
He was not listened to, and the desperation
of the German people at that time
became a Petri dish.
When you have large groups of desperate people,
it becomes a national security risk, whether it's
in a corner of the U.S. city or a corner of the world,
because large groups of desperate people become a Petri dish
out of which a certain level of societal dysfunction
is almost inevitable.
Ideological capture by genuinely psychotic forces
becomes pretty easy.
That's why the Marshall Plan.
That's why we treated Germany so well after World War II.
That's why we treated the Japanese
so well after World War II.
We knew that when people have been defeated,
don't keep kicking them,
something terrible is going to happen.
Even if you don't see it from a moral perspective,
just see it from a political perspective.
So you're absolute, right?
For 40 years, people have been kicked down.
"Vote for us, and it'll be better,"
"vote for us, and it'll be better,"
and at a certain point,
one man, who I don't think any of us thought
could've done that much damage so quickly,
who was willing to take advantage
of all the anger, all the anger,
to harness that for his own political purposes,
that coupled with what you mentioned,
the power of social media,
and we've gotten not only the problem we have on our hands
of a genuinely neo-fascist force field
but what should have been seen as a predictable one.
I believe if the Democratic Party had been truly holding
to its principles over the last 40 years...
Well, listen, if either political party had held
to their principles
over the last 40 years,
we wouldn't be where we are today.
Yeah, and it feels like
the Democratic Party can't get out of its own way.
It's very feckless in terms of how it's dealing with this,
with bullet points and policy initiatives
that fail to penetrate the emotional force field
of the people who could benefit from those policy shifts
the most, right?
There needs to be a broader conversation
where these people are actually feeling heard.
Well, these people were told, "Vote for us.
Stand in line for eight hours. Give us the White House.
Give us the Senate. Give us the House.
And we're gonna make your life better."
What happened to the conversation
of raising the minimum wage to $15 an hour?
about canceling the college-loan debt?
What happened to the conversation about Medicare for all?
They are peripheralized like it's a bunch of errant children
who don't know what they're talking about:
"too far left," even though the issues,
such as I just mentioned,
that are considered so far left in America today
are considered moderate, centrist views
in every advanced democracy (laughs) except for ours,
certainly in Europe.
And so to say to people...
I don't even think it's just the emotional force field.
It is their pocketbook,
and now the Democrat's wringing their hands:
"How are we gonna win in 2022?"
I'll tell you what you do.
You raise the minimum wage,
then people will vote for you.
You cancel those college-loan debts,
people will vote for you.
You pass Medicare for All,
It's really not rocket science,
and it's not just messaging.
It's not just messaging.
It's who they are willing to serve, at the end of the day.
And why can't they just get that done?
Because they, at the end of the day, are under the thrall
of the same corporate donors,
whether it has to do with the military-industrial complex,
whether it has to do with big pharmaceutical companies,
fossil fuel companies,
big agricultural companies,
big chemical companies,
not the NRA.
On that one, they are better,
but they're still not getting it done.
We all need to awaken (snaps).
It's like a woman who...
Her friends just have to say, "Honey, he's a bad guy.
He's not who you think he is."
At this point, these people are not doing it,
because they do not choose to.
Yeah, it was fascinating
to observe during your presidential bit
how the media treated you so unfairly,
the manner in which you were marginalized.
And I mentioned earlier I had Andrew Yang in here,
and he shared a little bit
about his personal experience with that,
which was a lesser version of what you experienced,
and he wrote quite extensively about it in his book.
But it was quite disheartening
to see the manner
in which you were maligned and made fun of and marginalized
when your debate performances
created so much conversation and a lotta interest.
And yet you would read the pieces about those performances,
and they were written with such a tone
of mockery and dismissal.
There's a causal relationship there.
After the second debate,
I was the most googled person in 49 states,
and clearly, somebody; we know his name;
Tom Perez, and that whole gang...
"Get her off the stage."
They knew that if I...
I was getting my sea legs in that second debate.
You're right.
I was talking about...
Environmental justice had not been discussed
as I did reparations,
a sickness-care system,
all of those things,
and by that third debate,
I woulda been an inconvenience.
And it was "get her off the stage,"
and within three days,
the talking points were so obvious:
"She's dangerous. She's crazy."
I (chuckles) love that one.
We're going back to ancient times, right?
"She's dangerous. She's crazy.
She's kooky. She's a crystal lady.
She's anti-vax. She's anti-science.
She's anti-gay."
It was the talking points.
You couldn't open your computer.
You couldn't turn on television
whilst someone wasn't saying it
and for exactly the reason you said.
These people who did that,
they didn't do it because they thought I was silly.
They did it because they knew that I was serious.
That's why they created the mischaracterizations
and the silly-girl bullshit,
because they knew that I was very, very-
Right, because if you were truly silly,
it's easy to be dismissive,
but if you're actually saying things
that are connecting with voters
and people are reacting and responding to that favorably,
then you become a threat
to the hegemony of the DNC
and their greater agenda, right?
Exactly.
All we know as citizens is...
We watch the debates.
We read the newspaper.
We scroll on Twitter.
We see the hot takes.
But what do we not understand?
You had this incredible firsthand experience
of (chuckles) running for president,
going behind the curtain,
and really seeing how the sausage is made
and the relationship between the media
and the campaign-industrial complex
Campaign-media-industrial complex.
Right, it's all intertwined.
Yeah, they chop their wood and carry their water.
I'm sorry. Go on.
I'm throwing it out to you.
Share a little bit
about what the average person doesn't understand
or might not get
about how that machinery actually functions.
Well, I felt in my case,
when all those things were said, there were two issues.
One was the smear,
and the other was how easily people were duped.
Would you really think
everything you read on the internet is true?
Grow up. (laughs)
No, (indistinct) people post an article, you know?
It's ridiculous,
and I know in my case,
when certain things would be said,
I was, I believe, ill-advised.
Don't respond to it, because it will pull attention to it,
but that's so ridiculous
because when you're running for president,
the attention is there.
If I were to do that again,
I would have gotten on Facebook Live
or whatever woulda been equivalent
and just spoke to it,
"No, the quackery here is not my views.
The quackery here is the journalism
that is saying these things.
Lemme tell you where the quackery is,"
and talked about the points.
It's such an assault.
It's such an ubiquitous assault,
so when you say,
"What does the average person not understand?"
I don't see the average person so much as a victim here.
As citizens we become lazy.
We become complacent,
and we need to wake up and realize
that misinformation is a much bigger field
than we even think it is,
that the whole thing has become
a corporate matrix and its minions,
who have these predetermined agendas,
predetermined sets of people
who it feels that it will allow
into the conversation
and the viciousness with which they will make sure
that anyone who they do not approve
will not be in the conversation,
I think when you were talking about Andrew...
Andrew did not get it nearly as bad,
and I think a large part of it is because he is a man,
Yeah, the layer of misogyny,
the craziness, and the wackiness.
Yeah, what makes him more of a businessman than...
I mean, come on.
(wind murmurs)
So are to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome,
but I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it,
so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable super-delicious
and easy-to-prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com,
and right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people,
for just $1.70 (chuckles) a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Yeah, so do you depart that experience?
How do you not find yourself cynical?
I suppose maybe you are cynical.
No, I hope I'm not.
I don't mean to project
on you, but.
I knew that the year after the...
First of all, in "The Course in Miracles," there's a line
that you pay a very high price
for not taking 100% responsibility for your own experience,
and the price you will pay
is that you won't be able to change it.
I am responsible for my experience.
I was not a victim.
I ran for president.
As someone said to me
after I was just ambushed in the most unfair way
by Anderson Cooper...
Someone said to me, and they were right,
"If you couldn't take on Anderson Cooper,
what would make us think you could take Vladimir Putin?"
Don't run for president
if you're not ready to take on what it was,
and there were too many ways
in which I was unprepared.
I naively thought
I was (chuckles) going to be judged on the issues.
People just like, "You didn't even have any,"
you know?
Right.
Or, at the very least, judged on my actual weaknesses
and the things that are true about me that are not perfect,
character defects, whatever.
I thought those would come up,
but this mischaracterization of wacky girl
who doesn't go to the doctor
and doesn't believe disease is real, what?
So I take responsibility.
That's number one, and number two,
what I knew I had to do was clear all that,
and that's what that year was about for me.
It's true. It's a cliche, but it's true.
You get bitter, or you get better.
Had to forgive myself.
Have to forgive others.
I didn't wanna go forward with a chip on my shoulder.
We all fall down in life,
but I think the issue is who gets back up and how.
Hemingway said, "Everybody's"...
What'd he say?
"Everybody's broken, but some grow stronger
at the broken places"?
So the issue for me is can I be a truth-teller
and point out what I think needs to be pointed out
without playing violence
like, "Poor me. What they did to me,"
because what they did to me is small
compared to the larger issue of what's being done
to the planet and to people all over the world.
Yeah, I just remember you being on the stage
and just very bluntly speaking truth to power
in a manner that was very bold and extremely unusual,
perhaps unprecedented for that type of dais,
(chuckles) to just say,
"Look, we gotta confront the dark with the light,"
and in a very matter-of-fact and convicted way,
and I think that's why you ended up getting googled so much:
"Holy shit, I've never seen anything like this before.
What are we gonna do with this?"
Well, the DNC had ideas
around that, of course.
Yeah, oh yeah, that though.
But I look at it as almost as if...
Listen, you knew
you weren't gonna win the presidency, right?
It's almost as if you were this Trojan horse
like, "I'm gonna insert myself into this equation,
and I'm going to seed the national dialogue
with certain ideas
that I think are hyper-relevant,
and I know that I'm gonna be perhaps mocked for them."
I did know. (scoffs)
"But I'm opening the door for the next person," right?
"I'm creating permission
so that this is can actually occur in the future."
It's like you were the courageous adventurer,
the first person to say,
"Let's talk about this more broadly.
Let's talk about this
from a broader, spiritual perspective,"
in a situation in which we have the Democratic Party
that has abdicated any relationship
with anything spiritual or religious in any regard.
That's been monopolized by the right in a certain way
and has left the Democratic Party fearful
of even talking about these things in a meaningful way.
I dunno about fearful.
I think that by surrendering,
we just abdicated the moral conversation.
Traditionally, on the political right,
they talked about issues of private morality,
and on their political left,
there were issues of public morality.
War and peace should be seen as a moral issue.
Whether you invade and country
that didn't do anything to you
is a moral issue.
Economic justice should be seen as a moral issue,
but over the last few decades...
And I don't even know how it happened.
Bobby Kennedy said
that the contest was for the soul of America.
JFK said, "We can't afford
to be materially rich and spiritually poor."
When I was growing up
during the anti-war movements of the 1960s and '70s,
Reverend William Sloane Coffin, the Berrigan brothers,
there was definitely a religious left,
so this is an aberration
that the left in America has become so overly secularized,
but I'd like to go back for a moment
to something you just said about...
"You opened the conversation."
"Oh, you brought up the conversation."
You know what? Lemme tell you something.
We don't have time left to just influence the conversation,
so yes, in my campaign,
hopefully, I did what you said,
"Opened the door," "next person," et cetera,
but this idea...
Sometimes people say, "Oh, Marianne,
you really influenced the consciousness of people."
The consciousness of people is not the problem.
That's not where the problem lies.
The problem lies is in those who are holding the levers
of political and economic power.
I have had the experience
of, quote, unquote, "advising" the most powerful people
in the country.
It's too late to just advise them.
We need to replace them,
so that goes back to this whole issue of incrementalism.
You don't go through a situation
as brutal as running for president
only wanting to influence the conversation,
not that I thought
that I would become president
in that election.
If somebody is sending you money to support your campaign,
even if it's $10,
you have, I think, an ethical responsibility
to play it as seriously as you can,
and I tried.
The fact that I, in moments of nervousness,
sounded silly clearly was used
by those who sought to mock me,
but once again, that's my responsibility.
I own it.
You've spoken many times
about the legacy and the impact of Bobby Kennedy and MLK
and what their assassinations meant
in terms of the chilling effect on activism,
this sense that we can be active or raise our voices
only to a certain degree
but that the powers that be are going to ensure
that that pressure valve gets released a little bit,
but as long as you go back and become a quiet citizen.
How do you reconcile that,
this idea, "okay, in the private sphere, go consume.
Do whatever you want.
And the public sphere, leave that to us"?
Here we are in a very precarious situation.
Can that be changed?
What you're saying, I think, is so important,
and as someone who lived through that,
the Kennedys, Dr. King,
the people who were holding aloft
the highest aspirations
philosophically, morally, spiritually,
were being channeled within a political context.
They were older than the youth movement at that time.
They were literally shot and killed in front of our eyes,
and it was very clear that the message was for all of us.
Those bullets psychically shot all of us.
It was a very loud unspoken message:
"There will be no further protest.
You will go home.
You will do whatever you want in the private sector.
You'll have a lotta choice, lotta choice.
You can have the yellow one. You could buy the blue one.
You can buy the red one. So much choice,"
and just in case we didn't get the message,
they killed the kids at Kent State.
We all did as we were told, but you know what?
Something has changed now
because that generation that was young then
has become older now,
and today, I know for myself
and I think for a lotta people in my generation,
the idea that we might die knowing in our hearts
that "the bastard got to us," as my father would say,
knowing in our hearts we didn't really do
what we came here to do in this lifetime
is actually scarier to us
than the thought that they might kill us if we do.
Now, you have tremendous, I believe, political potential
in harnessing the impulses
of those who are still young enough to dream,
and those who are experienced or old enough
to have now become wise.
I have never seen anything...
I don't think there's been in American history
like the way the U.S. government
collectively and systemically abuses our young.
It is unbelievable.
Between the college-loan debt,
the lack of health care,
the lack of availability of free education,
it's like instead of saying, "Hey, kids,"
like we would as parents,
"this country should not be run as a business.
This country should be run like a family.
We're gonna give you everything possible
so that you can go out there
and you can thrive and make it,
and we're gonna hold you accountable,
but we're gonna give you all the tools of success,"
we thwart the dreams of our young.
Where I see hope is how many young people really are...
They don't wanna take anymore.
They look at global capitalism,
and they say, "What has global capitalism ever done for me?"
and they look at socialism, and they go,
"What should I be so afraid of?
The free health care? Or the free college?"
The unfettered...
The whole orgy of deregulation that began in the 1980s
so that this shadow side,
the most irresponsible, amoral strain
of unfettered, unregulated capitalism
is now holding this...
The chokehold it has on the young,
the chokehold it has on our democracy,
you have young people who are just...
They're ready to break through this.
You have older people who are like,
"I'm not gonna die without weighing in on this,"
and we need to harness the political potential
of the dreamers and the wise.
Yeah, very well said.
That pendulum is definitely swinging back
from the Gordon Gekko "greed is good,"
rugged individualism, "me, me, me."
The rugged became rugged narcissism.
Yeah, we're reaping the havoc
of too many decades of that,
and we have these young people who...
(chuckles) You're very, right?
It's like, "Seriously?"
(scoffs) Yeah.
Not only is higher education restricted.
It's impossibly expensive.
I'll be saddled with debt
and then enter a job market
where there's no real legitimate opportunities
to move upward.
What are the options?
Right, and so these kids take out these college loans
in order to get an advanced degree
in the field that they want to pursue,
but then they actually can't take a job in that field
because they will not get the benefits that they need,
health care, et cetera.
They need to take the jobs that they hate
in order to ever pay back the college loans
which theoretically were giving them the education
for the life that they want.
Yeah, I feel a certain
(tuts) sense of urgent activism and energy that they have.
You talk about the aging up of the boomers
and their relationship with the legacy of activism
and Martin Luther King and Bobby Kennedy, et cetera,
and this sense of unfulfilled destiny
in terms of like manifesting the promise of that era,
but I see young people who are picking up that cause
and are not taking any bullshit.
Absolutely-
And you see that the protests at COP26-
That's what I was just gonna mention.
It was a perfect embodiment, what happened in Glasgow,
the people holding the power inside the building
were the incrementalists, were the apologists.
The greenwashing.
Yeah, and then you had hundreds of thousands,
or at least over 100,000,
of people on the street.
That's where the energy's going.
The issue is how fast and how much humans...
The issue is, number one,
will we be able to pull it off in time.
Number two (sighs)...
Sometimes, people say to me,
"Marianne don't worry about the Earth.
Don't worry about the environment,
because worse comes to worst,
Mother Nature will just have to kick off the planet
this predatory species
for 200,000-300,000 years, ha ha,
so the Earth will be okay,"
but I think we need to allow ourselves
to imagine the horror
of the amount of human and other-species suffering
that would result from that scenario.
Something fierce has to arise in us now,
You're a parent. I'm a parent.
There's something that happens,
usually when they're teenagers.
Usually, it involves sex or drugs.
There's fierce "that will not be happening in this house,"
and you don't even necessarily know what you would do
if they pushed you at that point,
but they're not gonna push you
because the look on your face is so serious.
That's how we have to become:
"That will not happen."
I do believe in my heart there are more lovers than haters.
There are more people yearning
for the good and the merciful and the humble and the true
and the beautiful and the democratic,
but there's a line in "The Course in Miracles"
where it says, "Miracles arise from conviction."
Conviction is a force multiplier,
so more people in this country and in this world
love than hate,
but those who hate, the bigots,
the racists, the antisemites,
the homophobes, the Islamophobes, they're convicted.
The terrorists, they are convicted.
I can't imagine
a kinda-sorta-sometimes-when-it's-convenient committed
terrorist or Proud Boy,
but too many of us who love
are willing to stand for our love on Tuesdays and Thursdays
between 2:00 and 4:00,
and I think people need to realize
you can't really wage a revolution over white wine and brie.
We have to become as convicted behind our love
as some people are convicted behind our hate.
If you have 10 people who hate with conviction
and 100 people who love but
with weak musculature, weak conviction,
then the conviction will carry the day.
Vladimir Lenin was asked,
"How are you going to be able to pull this off?
How are you ever going to be able to convince the peasants?"
He said, "I don't need to convince the majority.
I need 10 good men who understand what I'm talking about."
I think that we get too concerned about the majority,
and when you're too concerned about the majority,
you're willing to dumb down your message
because you think that social change occurs
on the horizontal axis.
I think social change now occurs on the vertical axis.
Go deep
with what's true.
It's always operated
that way.
And that's why the abolitionists won.
That's why the civil rights movement prevailed.
That's why suffragettes won,
but we need to step up our conviction.
It's my sense, Rich, that enough of us get it.
Enough people get it.
It's not like people are stupid.
And I found out as a candidate
the system was even more corrupt than I knew.
People were even more wonderful and intelligent
than I hoped for,
but we have to stand for what we know now and courageously,
and we'll be able to pull this off.
I certainly believe
that love is a more powerful force than hate,
but there is something very particular about hate
that lends itself to that level of conviction.
Hate is a very innervating
emotional state.
Adrenaline.
It's an agitation
that compels somebody
into a state of conviction,
whereas love doesn't really operate that way.
How do you function convicted around love?
I can understand being convicted
about justice or truth
or the difference between right and wrong,
but love is so much more...
It's elusive in that regard.
What is the fulcrum
that can create that situation
as a counterbalance to the amount
of convicted hate that we're seeing?
I'm not sure I see it totally the same way.
Look how you love your wife.
Look how you love your children.
It's not elusive or effusive.
It's fierce, but we need to...
When you learn history,
when you read American history,
when you read the history of Europe,
when you read the history of World War II,
you learn to have a fire in your belly
about freedom and about liberty and about democracy.
This is serious stuff.
There's such a failure of our educational system.
If you look at the Declaration of Independence,
those principles are a mission statement,
and what has happened
is that they have become emotionally eroded.
They're still written on marble walls,
and they're written on parchment,
and we hold it behind glass at the Smithsonian or whatever,
but too many generations have lost their moral force.
"All men are created equal."
We have to love that the way
we love our lovers, our spouses, our children,
that all men are created equal,
and all men have the inalienable rights
given by God
to life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness,
that governments are instituted to secure those rights,
and if government is not doing that job,
we have the right to alter it or abolish it.
I love that.
I love it just like I love a lover or a child.
To me, that's not elusive,
and that's why we have to teach our children.
And I also see it as the difference
between adrenaline and healthy food.
That's a good analogy.
Yeah, if anger is the motivating force
behind your activism,
it's like an adrenaline high.
It's a sugar high, and then you crash.
This is a marathon, guys.
But it's addictive too.
There's a dopamine hit with it.
(tuts) But as you well know,
your own work,
when you do eat healthy food,
it becomes its own driving force.
But it's a slower,
more gentle-
Yeah, it's slower,
but over time it gives you more energy,
and it gives you more peace than you realize.
But it's a process.
How do you think
about the role of spirituality in politics?
You mentioned earlier...
We were talking about how the Democratic Party has abdicated
any relationship with this
and is very secular in the way it conducts itself,
but the truth is most people have some form
of spiritual or religious life,
whether you're on the left or the right.
There's a religiosity to certain factions of the right,
but there is no real meaningful dialogue
around spirituality in politics.
These things are seen to be separate entities,
and part of your messaging or your ethos
is that these are the same thing.
We need an injection
of higher consciousness and spiritual awareness
in our politics.
If we wanna solve these problems.
First of all, there's a profound misunderstanding
of the whole concept of the separation of church and state.
The separation of church and state
is one of the most enlightened aspects
of the U.S. constitution,
but it was not instituted by our founders
to suppress the religious impulse.
It was instituted to protect it.
It has a dual function.
On one hand, it means that when Congress is meeting,
no minister, priest, rabbi, imam, ayatollah
is gonna walk in there
and say you can't pass this law
or you have to pass that law,
so it protects the government from interference
by religious authorities.
But it also means
that in this country,
no policeman or policewoman is gonna come
into a church, a mosque, a synagogue,
or an atheist meeting,
because religious freedom means not only the freedom
to worship as you wish
but whether or not you wish.
As Thomas Jefferson said,
"Whether a man believes in 20 gods or no gods
neither picks my pocket nor breaks my leg,"
so no one is going to be told
by governmental authorities,
"You cannot pray if you wish and how you wish."
So they weren't trying to shut people up.
They were trying to make sure that people were protected.
Now, that's the first thing,
that you don't give up your right as a citizen
to have an opinion
if your convictions are based
on spiritual or religious principles.
The over-secularization of the American left
has made too many people who do have religious convictions,
which is the majority of Americans, by the way,
feel that such thinking is unsophisticated,
it doesn't belong in the public realm,
and you need to shut up about it.
This has had very deleterious effects on American politics,
particularly for the left.
Now, if you look...
Go back to the Declaration of Independence,
"all men are created equal,
given by God the inalienable rights
of life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness."
On my Substack just last night
I published an article about abortion.
I'm very much pro-choice,
but I'm not pro-choice
with this idea that it's not a moral issue.
I think it's very much a moral issue,
but I trust the moral decision-making
of the American woman,
and I don't believe that the government should weigh in
on somebody's private moral decisions,
but those people who, over the last few years,
have deemed themselves arbiters
of the way Roe V. Wade could be discussed
have acted like any admission
that there's even a moral dimension to this question
would lead to political disaster.
I think the fact that we have failed
to contextualize it morally
is what has led to political disaster
such as we're experiencing now.
I think it's been a gift to the anti-choice movement,
and like I said, there used to be a religious left.
Today, if you are...
The black churches have never separated progressive politics
from religion and spirituality,
but anyone else is deemed...
(tuts) We're not supposed to be allowed to say it.
Sure, there's this coastal elite denigration
of anything religious or spiritual
where people who feel strongly
about their particular vein of faith
feel; misrepresented's the wrong word;
dismissed or condescend to.
Yeah, people don't like
to feel patronized.
I'm somebody who's been sober for a long time.
I got sober and stay sober
in the construct of 12 step,
and I always tend to evaluate problems and problem-solving
through the efficacy of 12 step,
which I know has overlap in the Venn diagram
with "The Course in Miracles" and your perspective.
Yeah, the 11th step, yeah.
This idea of...
You have strong feelings about reparations,
and the amends process is fundamental to recovery,
as is a spiritual connection
in a non-dogmatic way,
so when you look at rectifying
where we've gone off the rails
socially, politically, culturally,
there does seem to be a necessity
of inventorying those missteps
and actually implementing amends,
not just incremental policy change,
but how can we not only acknowledge the ills of our past
but also make them right
so that we can be whole as we move forward.
Well, the United States does need 12-stepping.
It needs to get out of its denial:
"I can handle this."
We've been going, "Can the Republicans handle it?
Can the Democrats handle it?
Which can manage this?"
The situation has become unmanageable.
(chuckles) My life has become unmanageable.
It's so true, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, it's amazing.
And once again,
like in the 12-
"But I got it."
Yeah, "I got it."
You don't got this. Your best thinking got you here, right?
And we're relying on the people that created the problem
to solve it,
telling us, "Go home.
It'll be fine."
Oh, and that's so much a part of the way
the political-media-industrial complex operates.
We're supposed to think that the only people qualified
to lead us out of this ditch
are people who have had careers ensconced in the car,
driving the car that led us into this ditch.
They act like we need better political car mechanics.
No, the problem is we're on the wrong road,
but that's a separate issue.
Let's go back to the 12 steps.
The 12 steps is a program of amends, obviously.
You have to admit your character defects,
you have to admit them to another person,
and you have to seek, where possible, to make amends.
In the Catholic religion, this is what confession is.
You have to atone.
In the Jewish religion, it's what Yom Kippur is,
the holiest day of the year, the Day of Atonement.
You have to admit the exact nature of your wrongs
and seek to make amends.
Now, when it comes to reparations for me,
I have for years been at my lectures
doing these ritualized apologies.
In my book "Illuminata," I have the ritualized apologies
to Native Americans, blacks in America, et cetera,
but I came to realize that if you took $1,000 from me,
I would really appreciate the apology,
but (chuckles) I also want my money back,
and so it got to the point
where we can talk about white privilege.
We can talk about deconstructing our own racism,
but at this point, I feel it's time
to do more than atone for slavery.
It's time to do more than atone
for the 100 years of institutionalized oppression of blacks
that occurred after the 250 years of slavery.
It's time to make amends now,
and like you were saying,
the same psychological and spiritual principles
that prevail within the life of an individual
prevail within the life of a nation
because that's all a nation is is a group of people.
Germany has paid $89 billion in reparations
to Jewish organizations
since World War II,
and this has gone far
to create a kind of emotional reconciliation
between Germany and the Jews of Europe,
not only the full mea culpa,
which they certainly did,
but also two things:
reparations and the guarantee that in perpetuity,
school children in Germany
would learn the history of the Holocaust
so that they would understand how these things start,
and that's where the United States is.
We have not evolved on the level of consciousness
to realize we will not be moving forward the way we want
until we do make this change.
Look at the history here.
World War II was over in 1945,
and look how much Germany has cleaned up.
Global antisemitism is an issue again,
but not based on that.
They cleaned it up.
My gosh, the Civil War was over in the 1860s.
We are still passing this toxic baton
of systemic racism
and the reactions and the horrors
of this evil
and how it has infused too much
of our economic functioning, et cetera,
generation to generation to generation.
We could be the generation to clean it up.
Well, look, Germany can't make the Holocaust
not have occurred,
but with reparations and the level of mea culpa,
they've gone far towards beginning again,
and the United States could do the same.
I feel like we're very far from that, though.
Not that we're in denial of that reality,
but it's dismissed
as politically suicidal
and economically unfeasible
Okay, if I may, this is
because we have such a corrupt political establishment
that follows rather than leads.
That should be the point of leadership within any system
but particularly within political leadership,
that you build consensus.
My experience as a candidate,
I would go into all-white audiences
in states that had such a small black population
that most of the people in the room
hadn't even had a lot of relationships with black people.
Let's say it was in New Hampshire,
or let's say it was in Iowa or someplace like that.
I walk into the room.
This was my experience over and over and over again,
including among white people
in states like South Carolina, okay?
I go into the room, and the subject of reparations comes up.
The body language I'm getting from people is like this,
and then I give a little 10-minute-maximum thumbnail sketch
of the history of race in America.
The first slave ships came here in 1619.
There was almost 200 years
of slavery in this country.
At the end of the Civil War, historians believe,
there was anywhere between four to five million people
who were formerly enslaved.
Those people were promised 40 acres and a mule
for every former-slave family of four.
Most of the time, it was not given.
Even when it was given, it was then repatriated.
What were people to do?
You tell somebody, "You're not a slave any longer,"
but how were you supposed to make a living?
If you had that 40 acres and a mule, you could.
The North sent, during the years of Reconstruction,
federal troops to the South
to guarantee that slavery would not be reinstituted.
Once they left, many in the South had just held their breath
until the soldiers from the North were gone,
and then they passed the black code laws,
which would ensure
subpar economic, political, and social opportunity
for black people.
That lasted almost 100 years
until Martin Luther King.
We passed the Voting Rights Act 1964-1965.
The Voting Rights Act to give black people...
To ensure their voting rights,
which now the John Roberts court has gutted,
which is why we have all these voting-suppression efforts.
Passed the Civil Rights Act to dismantle segregation,
so you've got 300 years
of institutionalized violence
against black people.
Now, anybody would, I'm sure, agree
that if you've been kicking someone to the ground,
and certainly kicking someone to the ground for 350 years
is quite a bit of kicking,
you morally and ethically owe it to them
not just to stop kicking
but to help them get back up,
and if Martin Luther King had lived...
They had dealt with voting rights.
They had dealt with civil rights,
and they would have gotten to the issue
of closing that economic gap
that was understandable
between whites and black
at the end of the civil rights movement.
And we've never closed it, and it's simply time.
I would go through this.
I would talk about the history,
and many of the things that I just said to you...
I'm sure none of what I just said to you, Rich,
was news or a surprise to you,
but you'd be surprised how many Americans
I don't believe are racist in their heart
but are just under-informed and undereducated.
The point of my story is that I would go through...
That's what I just told you,
and people whose body language had been like this,
at the end, are jumping up on their chairs,
standing ovations: "We need reparations."
Don't pin this on the American people.
That's what the politicians do:
"Oh, the American people don't want it."
No, you mothers don't want it,
and you won't go there,
and if it is politically suicidal, lose your job.
Why do politicians think they're the only people
who have jobs where they have to make ethical decisions?
And if I make the ethical decision, I might lose my job.
What's the answer to that in an ethical society?
Lose your job.
Reparations is the right thing to do.
From my experience
having run for president
and having talked about this issue all over this country,
I believe that the decency of the American people,
the dignitency of the American people,
the basic sense of right and wrong and fairness
of the American people,
could, indeed, be harnessed for this purpose.
When you're talking about even $500 billion,
you need make people recognize
the parties move in lockstep
to give the military-industrial complex,
what, 780 billion every year,
so we have to just bust through these illusions
and these myths and these toxic lies
that hold progress at bay,
and race relations, I think, is just one of many examples.
Yeah, it's very beautifully put.
It reminds me of what we were talking about earlier,
this difference or dissonance
between voter sentiment
and the establishment
of the political infrastructure
that is recalcitrant
and dictates what voters want and don't want
but in a way that's disconnected from the truth of that.
On such a level.
On the subject of defense budgets,
another idea that you've proposed that I love
is this idea of a Department of Peace,
which, when you think about it, yeah, okay,
can be "oh, how woo woo," but actually,
wouldn't that be the most prophylactic
in terms of maintaining comity across the world,
comity, C-O-M-I-T-Y,
(Marianne chuckles)
prevent these young people
from becoming disenfranchised
and thus radicalized
and thus a national security risk.
How do you preserve cohesiveness
in our country and in other countries across the world
as an insurance policy against war,
to begin with,
which is much more expensive once we're waging it?
Unfortunately, American foreign policy
is not run or driven
by the idea of an effort to create comity within the world.
It's like medicine.
Of course.
It's basically about disease management
and treating symptoms
as opposed to being preventative.
Right, so let's talk about why that is though.
As John F. Kennedy said,
"We will end war, or war will end us."
The American foreign policy establishment is...
You look at $40 billion budget
for the State Department
versus the 780 billion-or-more budget
for the Defense Department.
Whereas the State Department used to drive
American foreign policy,
it doesn't not so much now.
Raytheon, Northrop Grumman, Boeing,
the defense contractors,
short-term profits for defense contractors
is what now drives our military policy.
If you do what you just said...
Statistically, we know what creates greater peace.
There are four factors
that create a higher incidence of peace
and a reduced incidence of violence:
expanded economic opportunities for women,
expanded educational opportunities for children,
the reduction of violence against women,
and the amelioration of unnecessary human despair.
Yeah, you're right.
You do that, you'd have a more peaceful world.
Where are the corporate profits there?
And that's all that this is about.
This is about a sick game of merchandising death.
We don't have universal access
to universal health care,
because of the profit-making factor
for health insurance companies
and big pharmaceutical companies.
We don't have anything near what we need
in terms of mitigating climate change,
because of short-term profits for fossil fuel companies.
And we don't have anything close to a foreign policy
that is driven by an agenda for peace
over the next 100 years,
because of profit-making factor
for the military-industrial complex.
And this is one of the ugliest monopolistic...
We talk about the corporate duopoly
of the political parties.
What's important is for us to realize the ways
in which they're not a duopoly.
They're a monopoly,
and one of the places where they are monopolistic
is in complete lockstep
with the military-industrial complex.
Course, they don't want a Department of Peace,
because a Department of Peace...
You wouldn't just have a military academy.
You'd also have a peace academy.
You'd have people who were resourced
in building peace, in peace-building measures.
When I was running for president,
all over the country, this would happen.
I would talk to people who were helping children
because this is where it all starts.
If you want peace in the world,
we need a massive front-ending.
I also want a Department of Children and Youth.
We need to massively front-end our resources
in the direction of people 10 years old and younger.
Now, the average American, I don't think, registers
how many millions of American children are food-insecure.
I don't think the average American registers
how many millions of Americans live in food deserts,
people who cannot get access to fresh fruits and vegetables.
How many of our obese children...
You know why these kids are obese?
Because their bodies keep trying
to get the necessary nourishment.
So they're actually under-nourished.
They're not over-nourished. They're under-nourished.
That's why they keep eating calories,
so they go, and they eat more M&M'S,
or they eat more crap fast foods,
trying to get-
They live in food deserts
where healthy food is not available,
and the cheap low-hanging fruit is in the bodegas,
and that's what they're eating.
But this is where...
The corporate profits do not lie in helping them.
The survival of our democracy lies in helping them.
The survival of our species lies in helping them,
so just as we need to make a just transition
from a dirty economy to a clean economy,
we need to make a just transition
from a war economy to a peace economy.
And it's the same issue.
A lotta people would say,
"Why is it that these politicians continue
to walk in lockstep?"
In large part because of the jobs created
in their districts and in their states
by defense-related activities.
We spend hundreds of billions every year
over what even military leaders say is actually needed
for our military security,
but just as with a dirty economy,
the same talents and expertise
of research and development, manufacturing, et cetera,
can move in the direction of peace.
And it is also statistically true
that a peace economy where your investment is
in education, health care, economic opportunity, et cetera,
gives you more of an economic return on investment.
Raytheon ain't having it, though.
Oh, Raytheon is not having it,
but we have to have it.
We've got to say it.
We've got to stand on it.
We've got to run on it.
I love the idea, but ultimately,
do we not have to disentangle campaign finance laws
and find a way to (chuckles) prevent
this insane undue influence
that these industries have on legislatures?
It's anti-democratic in every-
It's the cancer underlying-
Yeah, and it's like, "Can't we all find some way
to fundamentally agree on that?"
Well, I think the American people do agree on it.
Sure, I think they do too.
But the undue influence of money on our politics,
particularly corporate money,
is the cancer underlying all the other cancers,
particularly dark money,
particularly that which has exploded since Citizens United.
We certainly need to repeal that,
but that's not gonna happen anytime soon.
Ultimately, we will need a constitutional amendment
that establishes public funding for federal campaigns.
I don't think most people realize
that your average congressman spends half their time
on the phone
trying to raise money.
Probably more than half their time.
It's so insane.
It starts on day one.
And yet these people, we're supposed to look at them
and go, "Oh, they're so qualified for leading us forward."
(Rich laughs)
It's the Ken on the Barbie dolls.
You were talking about the manner
in which money goes into...
The medicalization of-
The sickness-care system rather than the-
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, we don't have a health care system.
We have a sickness-care-
But it's metastasized
into much more than that, right?
We've medicalized sadness and grief.
We're overmedicating everybody,
and that also speaks
to the undue influence
of these huge pharmaceutical companies
and their financial interests
in making sure that everybody is adequately medicated
at all times.
Absolutely, and that's
another reason they came after me, actually,
on the campaign.
Yeah, and that's
not to say that medication certainly does...
It has its place
in mental health.
Oh, of course, it does.
In appropriate situations,
but as somebody who understands very well the difference
between what one might consider clinical depression
versus grief or having a hard time
and the fact that we're now giving people pills
that just are going through something
that they need to go through
because we're human beings
and life is hard...
I look at antidepressants the way I look at painkillers.
They have a place, but we now know
the Sackler family, Purdue Pharmacy, et cetera...
We know about predatory behavior
on the part of pharmaceutical executives,
creating profit centers,
dangerous immoral profit centers,
where they do not belong.
And I think it is absolutely naive of us
to think that that's not happening
in relation to antidepressants as well,
and the fact that if you even suggest that,
you are considered naive or irresponsible
about mental health is absurd.
What's happening is how naive and irresponsible people are
to so blindly trust big pharmaceutical companies,
and like you said, they do wonderful things.
My God, I had surgery not long ago,
and believe me, I was grateful for those painkillers.
Of course, they have a place,
as do, I'm sure, in many people's lives, antidepressants,
but the fact that you can't even suggest
that the overprescription of medication in America
is a real issue
and we should be able to talk about it,
that has to do with the chokehold of big pharma
and the fact that the military,
excuse me, not the military
but the political system and the media,
like when Anderson Cooper came after me,
talking about that issue...
And I said, "Well, that's interesting
because look how many pharmaceutical companies advertise
on your television show."
And he said, "I don't know who advertises."
I wish I said to him-
It's constant pharma ads.
And by the way, before Ronald Reagan,
this was not legal.
Pharmaceutical companies could not advertise on television
before Ronald Reagan
and the orgy of deregulation
that his administration brought forth.
(tuts) Yeah, it's a sticky wicket.
It's all one and the same, though.
All of these issues go back
to this inextricable connectivity
between government and giant conglomerates.
And also you bring in on the sickness issue,
and one of the things I brought up in a debate was,
that we have to ask ourselves,
"Why is there so much more chronic illness
in the United States than among citizens
of other equally advanced, European, democratic societies,
for instance?"
This goes back, as you well know...
You talk about this.
This goes to our chemical policies,
our agricultural policies,
animal factory farming.
And subsidies.
Yeah, it's a whole corporate matrix.
We have this corporate aristocracy.
We have reverted to an aristocratic condition.
And we have to understand what that archetype means.
An aristocracy means
that a few people are considered entitled
to the major resources of the country.
We repudiated that in 1776,
and we need to repudiate again.
It's outrageous,
the idea that profit-making
for companies whose practice of capitalism
is so predatory
that it is constantly at the expense,
or at the very least too often at the expense,
of the health and wellbeing of people and planet,
the American people have every right in the world
to push back against this.
It is the most traditionally American thing in the world
We've never been a perfect union, obviously.
We had slavery from our inception.
We've always been a dichotomy.
You had, out of the 51 signers
of the Declaration of Independence
establishing these enlightened principles,
more enlightened than had ever been encoded
in the founding documents of a country,
46 of the 51...
Or is it 41 of the 56?
I think it's 41
of the 56.
I think it's 41.
Were themselves slave-owners,
so we've always been this dichotomy
between people who held in our hearts this flaming love
for what was possible
versus people willing to transgress
in the most violent ways
against the execution of those principles.
Our generation in that sense is no different than any other,
and other generations have pushed back,
and I just pray in my heart
that we will not be the first generation of Americans
who wimp out on doing what it takes
to say hell no to that kind of nonsense.
(tuts) All of these ideas and themes
are most perfectly crystallized
in this Steven Donziger situation
that I know that you've been very active-
Thank you for bringing it up.
In speaking about.
So explain a little bit
for people who don't know this situation,
'cause it's unbelievable.
In the 1960s, then-oil-giant Texaco went down
to the Amazon in Ecuador
at the Ecuadorian Amazon swath of the Amazon River.
Now, already, Ecuadorian environmental regulations
were less than ours,
and ours were never so wonderful.
They were even less than ours.
Even in violation of those, Texaco,
in order to save $3 a pit,
left their pits unlined,
and they admit that they did this,
thus poisoning that area of the Amazon,
the food, the water, even the air.
They would actually say
to the indigenous farmers down there,
"Oh it's good for you.
This oil has vitamins in it. It's mothers' milk."
(Rich laughs)
I know it's so evil.
It's like farming with Brawndo from "Idiocracy."
Steven Donziger, Harvard-educated lawyer, leads a team,
goes down there, realizes what's happened,
leads a team of lawyers in holding
what was by then Chevron accountable because Chevron
had bought Texaco.
They bought Texaco.
Chevron doesn't even deny that happened,
so Chevron said, "We don't want the case tried
in the United States.
We want the case tried in Ecuador,
and if it is tried in Ecuador,
if we are held accountable or liable,
we will pay whatever the judgment is."
The judgment that came down
ended up at somewhere $8-9 billion.
Yeah, it was like 9 1/2 billion.
And this is a while ago.
Oh yeah, that's right.
This has been going on for years.
Chevron said, "Hell no,"
and ended up coming at Steven Donziger,
and they had sought to destroy his life,
and they had him on this misdemeanor where they claimed
that he had...
There was some money that they said he owed them.
They wanted access to his computer.
Now, we all know how sacrosanct the relationship
attorney-client privilege is.
Attorney-client privilege.
The last thing he wanted to do
was to give over his computer
in which there was all this contact information
about Ecuadorian environmental activists.
He wouldn't do it.
He was filing an appeal,
and what happened there was; this was just a misdemeanor;
New York State said, "We're not even gonna deal with this."
Judge Lewis Kaplan found a loophole
and basically gave over the prosecution
of Steven Donziger to Chevron.
This is very important that we see this for what it is.
This is Chevron and, I think, in many ways
on behalf of the entire fossil fuel industry
putting its line in the sand,
trying to freeze human rights and environmental activism,
saying, "You go this far, we will destroy you."
Steven Donziger was held in home detention
for over two years
with an ankle bracelet.
He was denied a jury trial,
and Judge Preska;
these people are all related
to the Federalist Society, et cetera;
on behalf of Chevron basically,
using a law firm which is Chevron-related,
has now thrown the book at him,
and he has now in Danbury prison in Connecticut
serving a six-month prison sentence.
And what we want is for Merrick Garland to take this case,
and several congresspeople have written a letter.
The UN High Commissioner on Human Rights
has called this political prisoner,
has said that it is a human rights abuse,
has said that he should be released
and he should be paid money in recompense.
Greenpeace...
There is more and more of a building energy
of the outrageousness of this.
He's basically a political prisoner.
At this point, it's not just
that Merrick Garland needs to step up.
Merrick Garland needed to step up a while ago.
Joe Biden should step up.
Joe Biden should step up and commute this sentence now.
This is such a crazy situation.
First of all, Chevron still hasn't paid the 9.5 billion.
But they will pay any amount of money, they've said,
in order to prosecute Steven Donziger
because they realize
that if you let this go through...
That's the way
the fossil fuel companies are looking at this.
It's all about freezing
environmental and human rights activism.
Yeah, it's so crazy
that they've been able to amplify
what is essentially a misdemeanor charge
on a trumped-up, I think, fraud claim, where he's just like,
"Look, I'm not turning over my phone and my laptop."
Ordinarily, that would be...
So there's a contempt charge, right?
But that would be a fine or a slap on the wrist
or something like that.
Two years-
With an ankle bracelet and the six months
now in addition.
And then six months.
It's unbelievable.
It is unbelievable.
And it's clearly sending
this chilling-effect message on anybody
to say, "Not so fast. Not so far."
Yeah, it's the not so far.
But there is so much energy in this case.
People are talking about it,
and he's been very forthright,
and he's been doing videos and stuff like that
from his home
before he went to Danbury,
and you've been doing Instagram Lives with him
and stuff like that.
And it's a fascinating test case
and an example
of just how far a company like Chevron will go
to make sure that anybody who challenges them
in a meaningful way
will get put in the grave.
Also, I don't think
the average American knows...
I certainly was shocked.
Everybody I know was shocked.
Who knew that there was a loophole-
Yeah, I still don't understand how this came to be.
I was at the trial, the first part of it, the first day.
A Chevron-sponsored lawyer comes in
and uses a U.S. courtroom.
This is a show trial.
This is the corporate prosecution of a U.S. citizen.
This is a corporate prosecution of a U.S. citizen.
Right, in the context of a civil trial.
It's not even criminal court.
It's wild.
Yeah, these (indistinct) just one of many things
that's, quote, unquote, "not supposed to happen in America,"
but it is happening,
and that goes back to what you and I were saying earlier.
We can't just influence the conversation.
We need to stop this.
I can't end this without talking to you a little bit
about the idea of forgiveness
because that's so central
to your core philosophy and perspective on everything.
How do we develop the facility to forgive?
And why is that so important
in terms of living our lives
in a manner in which to be most whole and complete?
Well, I'm a student of "A Course in Miracles,"
and the concept of forgiveness,
which is central to "A Course in Miracles,"
presents the word in a very different way
than it is presented
within traditional Christian terminology
or any religious terminology.
Usually, when we think of forgiveness,
it's "you're a jerk,
but I'm so spiritual now that I deign to forgive you."
The condescending, my favorite kind of forgiveness.
It's "judgment to destroy,"
"The Course in Miracles" says, but forgiveness
within a deeply spiritual metaphysical concept
means knowing that we are all created by God
as innocent and good
and we make mistakes
and that God does not punish us for our sins.
Sin is an archer term. Means you miss the mark.
He seeks to correct us for our mistakes,
and when you are in that place, you realize
that the love that is who you are and who I am is real.
The rest is this mortal hallucination that we're having.
Buddha called it an illusion.
Einstein said, "Time and space
are illusions of consciousness,
albeit persistent ones,"
that there is some bedrock
of love, unalterable love,
that is the truth of who we are.
And I think that everything
that we're talking about today...
If you stand on that,
that our function on this earth
is to see that love in each other
and to stand on that love
and to invoke that love,
everything changes.
Your criminal-justice system changes.
Your economic system changes.
Your personal relationship changes.
Your treatment of the Earth changes.
Now, that doesn't mean you don't say no.
Sometimes love says no.
Forgiveness doesn't make you a doormat.
Forgiveness simply makes you someone
who is capable of owning your yes and owning your no.
You have children.
If a small child walks into the kitchen
"hi, Mommy, Daddy, look at this razor blade I found,"
it is incumbent upon you, out of love for that child,
to make sure the razor blade is taken out of their hands,
but you don't look at that child and forget who they are
just because they were so uninformed
and not old enough to realize
you can't play with razor blades.
Forgiveness means knowing that who we are is good.
Living on this earth, we forget that,
but when I look at you and I
base my perception of you only on your error,
only on your lovelessness,
then I am stuck within that realm of lovelessness.
And "The Course of Miracles" says,
"You are at the effect of the laws
that prevail within the world that you identify with."
If I'm willing to extend my perception
beyond what my physical senses perceive,
your error, your lovelessness,
to what I know to be true in you,
then I remind both you and myself what is true in us,
and the situation repairs.
And we're gonna have to do that on a larger level.
The hatred, the cynicism, the anger
on both the left and the right
dispels and deflects the possibility
for political miracles,
and we must open our hearts
and still passionately disagree, form boundaries.
Just like you have boundaries in personal relationships,
you have boundaries in political relationships,
but you can do all of that with love.
You can do all of that with respect and humility,
and to me, that's the portal
through which we can walk to a more sustainable world.
The resistance to forgive,
that impulse that we feel
when we sense that we've been wronged,
is ostensibly to shoulder a burden.
It's a self-punishment, right?
And there is a liberation or a freedom that happens
when you can develop the facility
to let go of it, to forgive,
as difficult as that might be.
And that forgiveness should be turned inward as well.
Self-forgiveness is
a big piece of that as well.
Well, you can't forgive
yourself if you don't forgive others.
That's why the course says,
"You become generous out of self-interest."
The course says when you're attacking someone,
blaming someone, imagining
that there is a sword falling down on their head...
But it's actually falling down on yours
because at the deepest level,
if you get into the metaphysic of it,
there's no place where you stop and I start.
None of us except enlightened masters
are perfect at any of this,
but even making the transforms our lives.
Yeah, we've all seen our soul elevated
by witnessing somebody forgive somebody
where logic would dictate that maybe they shouldn't,
and we understand fundamentally
that that is a noble act,
that that is nourishing.
And yet we're in a culture
where we're increasingly judging everybody
based on their worst day
and canceling people
and saying, "You go away now"
and "that's it for you."
There is no room,
at least in the social media space,
for that forgiveness,
and unless we find a way back to that,
a way to prioritize it
and inject it into our discourse and conduct,
we're lost.
You are so right.
I think you put it so well.
We're judging everybody according to their worst day
or their most stupid tweet.
Everything's "I gotcha."
It's terrible.
Many years ago, my best friend, who has since passed...
We were sitting in my bedroom,
and I was on the phone
with someone who worked for me,
and I started yelling at the guy.
I got off the phone, and Richard said to me,
"What was that?"
and I said, "Well, he did this" or "he didn't do that"
or whatever it was,
and Richard looked at me, and he went, "Marianne,
he made a mistake.
People make mistakes."
(sighs) It was a brick to my forehead I remember.
And no matter what he did,
the fact that you were such a bitch about it
makes you no better than...
(sighs) I got it.
I'm not 100% at practicing it
but a lot better than I used to be,
because people make mistakes.
Yeah, how do we try
to create space for that?
"The Course in Miracles" says you say,
"Dear God, I'm willing to see this differently."
The path that we are here to monitor is not somebody else.
It's like you were talking about AA.
You're not here to take somebody else's inventory.
The path you're here to monitor very vigilantly is your own.
Dear God, I see how self-righteous I am in this moment.
Dear God, I see how judgmental I am in this moment.
Dear God, I see how blaming.
Who do hell how do I think I am?
Dear God, take this away from me.
And I see this all the time.
Then what happens is
sometimes you realize "just keep your mouth shut.
There's nothing that even needs to be said."
Sometimes you realize "oh, there's something
that's gonna need to be communicated here,"
but you will communicate it from such a different place.
You will communicate it
from elegance and charity and compassion.
"The Course in Miracles" says,
"If you're judging and attacking someone,
you're wrong even if you're right."
(tuts) Right, but we have a social media ecosystem-
Oh yeah, we do.
That has a misalignment of incentives
because it's rewarding people
for that level of judgment and invective.
We do, but each and every one of us
can refuse to participate in that and do what we can,
because there's also some beautiful stuff on social media.
There's a line in the course
where it says, "Nothing in the world is unholy or holy,
except determined by its purpose,
what the mind is doing with it,"
and you can see incredible things, credible good,
that comes from social media,
and you can see terrible, even evil, things
that emerge from social media.
And it all gets back to the ethics and the principles
of right and wrong and enlightenment
that I do think so many of us are at least trying for.
Yeah, it's sometimes difficult
to understand the best move;
for example, (tuts) the other day,
Massie, that congressman, the guy from Kentucky
who posted the holiday photo
of his whole family-
"Jesus, send the ammo"?
(laughs) With the guns.
And I saw that, and I was so appalled.
We're days away from school shooting.
Normally, I don't mix it up on social media
and inject myself
into that kind of discussion or acrimony,
but I felt like I couldn't let it stand.
I tweeted it and said,
"I just feel like these people are...
It's difficult to imagine
how weak, insecure, and broken these people must be
to think that this is a good idea to share this photo."
It was met with a lot
of different (chuckles) opinions obviously,
and then I thought, "I probably shouldn't have tweeted that.
Why am I doing this?"
Or is there a responsibility
to say something
when somebody does something
that I feel is so deeply inappropriate?
Well, I think on that one,
and where I land on that one is,
that it's not about Massie.
It's about that school shooting in Michigan.
Within two days in Oakland County in Michigan,
due to credible threats of mass shootings,
every single public school in the county was closed.
Now, I raised my daughter in Michigan.
I have a lotta friends there.
There's an inflection point.
It's really interesting what's happening there.
A lot of people who would not necessarily have gone there,
since then, have said, "This gone too far."
Americans are afraid to send their kids to school,
but this is also an issue
where the consciousness of the American people
is not the problem.
Poll after poll shows
the American people want to close those loopholes.
Poll after poll shows the American people want
to outlaw bump stocks.
The polls show the American people want to rid our streets
of average citizens
who are carrying assault weapons,
AR-15s, AK-47s, et cetera.
This has to do with the chokehold
that the NRA and gun manufacturers has
on our Congress,
so it all goes back to money and politics.
But the idea
that right now a bogus interpretation
of the second amendment...
This is not about the second amendment.
This is about the money of gun manufacturers
and the hold that this holds
in terms of congressmen and senators who are told,
"If you vote for the most common-sense gun-safety law,
we're coming after you, and you're gonna lose your job."
And we need more of them will say, "Fine, I'll lose my job."
And right now...
I don't think a lotta people realize
the first official act of Donald Trump
when he became president
was to repeal a law
that kept violent criminals
from being able to buy a gun.
Yeah, I knew that.
The NRA will not be happy...
They even have little gun holsters in pink
for our little girls.
I know, so how do you maintain hope amidst all of this?
Because I believe that love prevails.
The crucifixion was followed by the resurrection.
The slavery in Egypt was followed
by deliverance to the Promised Land.
"The arc of the moral universe is long,
but it bends towards justice."
Even if, God forbid, there is a nuclear Holocaust
on this planet
and only five people are left,
those five will look at each other and go,
"Let's do it different this time."
It's gonna happen.
It's that symbolic three days
between the crucifixion and the resurrection,
the symbolic 40 years
between slavery in Egypt
and deliver into the Promised Land.
That is a sign.
There is a limited period of time.
What is up to free will
is will that be three years, three decades,
3,000 years, 30,000 years, lifetimes.
That is in our hands.
I believe in people.
It's economic systems and political systems
that are holding all this back right now,
but I believe that love will prevail,
because I believe that it always has.
It always will.
That's not only my religious and spiritual conviction.
It's my experience.
(tuts) I think that's a beautiful place to end it.
Thank you.
You are a powerful and magnificent human being.
I appreciate-
Thank you.
The work that you do.
The message and the vibration
that share with the world,
it is very powerful.
I guess the only thing left to ask you
is where are you taking this,
what is next for you,
or where are you placing your focus.
I think that there are these impulses
that are collective in the zeitgeist,
and I'm where everybody I else I know is,
where I bet, to some extent, you are,
everybody in this room is,
asking that question.
I think that's the question of the conscious person
right now: how can I best serve?
And we're living the question, living the inquiry,
me no less than everybody else I know.
But new connections are being made, ya know?
It's like an immune system, right?
The body survives
because there's an amazing amount
of assault and injury and illness that the body can take
as long as there's a healthy immune system.
I believe the psyche has an immune system.
It's amazing how much heartbreak and trauma we can take.
There's a psychic immune system,
and I believe there's an immune system in civilization
and the immune cells are awakening.
I remember I once fell down, cut my hands.
I was running, and I fell.
These huge gashes on my hands, it was so fascinating
to watch the wound 'cause it was right here,
and I remember a doctor friend of mine saying,
"You realize the red is good news.
It means all the white blood cells are rushing
to the wound,"
and that's what I feel is happening right now.
Everybody's rushing to the wound,
and cells in the body are assigned:
"You (snaps) go to the lungs.
You (snaps) go to the heart.
(snaps) You go to the bones,"
and right now we're all being assigned
to the area of the wound
where we can best make a difference.
And I know for myself and for most people I know,
we're not quite sure
where the assignment is right now,
but we can wake up every day
and do what we can to be the awakening.
Yeah, find the wound that speaks to you, right?
I feel like
(tuts) so many forms of new media,
like podcasting, et cetera,
play such a vital role in this.
It's providing so many people
with different avenues
for learning and exploring media
that just weren't available not that long ago,
and I feel like that's a big piece
in the construction of this strong immune system.
Absolutely, because traditional media...
It's so corporatized and bought and sold
it's that predetermined agenda,
and this is independent media,
people having a deeper conversation.
It was Werner Erhard who said,
"You can live your life from circumstances,
or you can live your life from a vision"
and things such as you're doing
allow us to have a vision of what's possible,
and from that, anything is possible.
Beautiful, well, you can learn more
about Marianne and all of her wisdom
by subscribing to her Substack,
which is pretty new, right?
"TRANSFORM," you just started getting into this?
And you also have a podcast, "TRANSFORM" podcast.
Is there anywhere else that you wanna direct people towards
that wanna learn more about you,
aside from your over-a-dozen books
that (chuckles) you've written?
Yeah, well, people can go to Marianne.com
and sign up on my mailing list
for the various things I do
or Substack, and "The Marianne Williamson Podcast" is
on that Substack.
Yeah, if you go to Marianne.com,
you can get to the Substack from there as well, right?
All right, well, come back and talk to me again sometime.
Thank you. Thank you for everything you do.
It was an honor to be here.
Thanks. Peace.
What?
(tranquil music)
(mechanism whirs)
(whirring slows)
(music fades)